so hello my name is Rafael Medina I'm
associate professor at the premiere of
infectious diseases and immunology in
Kafala University in Chile and today I
would like to share with you some of the
data that we have been producing for the
last seven years or so as as we haven't
developed a human cohort to try to
really understand in death pathogenesis
of human influenza viruses and I like to
share with you some of the new systems
biology approaches that we have been
using because our main goal is to try to
understand global phenomenon and from
there move on into dissecting molecular
factors that affect this is outcome so
just as a brief background I would like
to share these ideas with you that I
think will make it make sense to a lot
of us as we look at some of the recent
phenomenon with emerging infectious
diseases and their potential for causing
outbreaks and pandemics so what we have
under right-hand side of your screen as
some natural reservoirs and ecological
niches that can affect or influence the
emergence of some of these infectious
diseases therefore you can see that
there is physical environmental and
climate change factors that might indeed
potential diseases as for some of the
samples that we have seen with influenza
itself but also we never seek and
chikungunya in the last few years now in
regards to you how this potential and
manufacturers can effects effect as
humans as hosts we also know that there
are some people that are more
susceptible to becoming infected with
some of these diseases and in this
regard there are several factors that
one can take into account one of them is
cultural how we perceive some of these
infectious diseases in nature there are
political issues economic issues the
capacity of health systems but also the
hosts themselves in for
elderly children and pregnant women are
known to be acceptable to some diseases
and this in particular is true for
influenza viruses but there is also a
number of what we think are healthy
individuals that can also become
susceptible to infectious diseases and
even a die or have a very severe disease
and there are factors and molecular
factors that are currently unknown of
why this happens and now if we move more
into some of the molecular factor into
place of course there's a plethora of
different phenomenon that we can look at
some of those could be in the virus
itself this is what we do with influenza
virus in our group but also there is
pre-existing conditions and
comorbidities clinical profiles of the
individuals that become infected now
there is also a big push to trying to
understand other factors that coexist
with that which is the microbiome for
examples in which we have been looking
at but I don't have time to talk to you
about this today and also there is
genetic susceptibilities so certain
genes that may I allow certain factors
to be triggered or not to be triggered
that are necessary to combat infectious
diseases and a big portion which I put
there in the middle is how the host
immune responses that we generate upon
infection help us to clear the virus but
in many cases we have been learning that
immune responses also can contribute
until this is severe and I've tried to
talk a little bit about that in my talk
to show you what we have been doing in
that we are so I'm telling you two
stories which I think summarize some of
the things that we have been doing and
to show you how the different tools that
we have been using to to understand this
instability outcome and host factors
that are at play so again our primary
goal of
is to perform systematic and
comprehensive analysis of factors
contributing to the system early and
like I said some of the factors that we
have been looking at and I will tell you
today is influenza virus phenotypes and
genotypes and how we think these can
actually influence the system early and
we also will be talking a little bit
about host immune responses and how they
also play a role in this is outcome so
this is to show you what the seasonal
influenza virus epidemiology looks in
children and this is showing you the
last five years and as you can see the
different colors depict the different
seasonal strains that circulate in the
population over the year with the light
blue here showing the H one and one
seasonal influenza virus the red shows
the h3n2 seasonal influenza virus the
green shows the influenza B and yellow
is some of the an subtype viruses that
recur every system because as most
health systems you know subtype every
you know 100% of the words of the
circulate but you can get a very nice
trend of what was the predominant strain
and how the different peak of cases
occur every year like to highlight for
example this current year nine to nine
2019 we had a very strong Pig of h1n1
circulation but as we just are finishing
now our system which is very late
finishing of our system here we had a
very strong peak of influenza B in the
springtime really so this is just to
kind of emphasize the influenza virus
can circulate in nines at pretty much
any time here in the year and it's got
to do probably because of susceptibility
and lack of immune responses to
potential viruses that circulate every
year so as I said we have been
systems biology approach to understand
this virus and we have developed with
the collaboration of our clinicians here
at the University Hospital is to perform
a longitudinal study where we recruit
patients that have acute infections
coming to the hospital and then we
consent them and ask them to join the
the clinical investigation that we do
and we take several samples in order to
understand the immune responses and also
in order to understand virus so as you
can see there in the acute phase we take
samples of blood samples which are the
red noodles and the rectangles are on
day one or upon treatment and then also
a convalescent phase sample on day 28 so
we use this serum and blood samples to
understand seroconversion
but also to understand cytokine
responses early on and later on this is
going to that in a little bit more
detail the green boxes there also show
the names of radials for us that we take
from these patients and this allow us to
follow the virus over the first seven
days of infection and the first idea of
that and we should I will show you in
the second part is to try to understand
whether the virus changes over time now
as I'm listening here in the bottom
these are all the different assets that
we can actually do and perform try to
understand in a global way how influenza
virus affects the immune response at the
antibody level cytokine response of
course this as I said is how the
infection is being control or not early
on and during the convalescent phase of
the infection now new techniques allow
us as well to perform more in-depth
studies and we're moving into these I'm
going to show you any of this for now
but we're conducting some single-cell
analysis to try to understand
how the expression of different profiles
from severe and non-severe individuals
can allow us to differentiate what
global networks are being triggered
during infection and you know the same
thing we do with our NAC by just
performing an overall global
transcriptomic analysis of these samples
on the top there you can also see that
the nasal swabs we isolate the viruses
we subtype them and we do foo genome
sequencing from all the viruses that we
take we obtain from these patients and
together with the clinical make the data
that we obtain from from the same cohort
we are able to do what we call is a high
dimensional multi-screen network
analysis that allow us to pinpoint not
only two specific genes but two networks
and to global responses that then allows
to make hypotheses based on very
in-depth analysis of a lot of data
that's that's that's what I think what
we think is the power of our cohort
analysis platform so I'll tell you a
first set of studies that we have done
with patients from 2011 to 2013
we're here in stable I'm showing you
that we have obtained data from maybe
three severe patients sorry maybe three
is none of your patients and 129 severe
patients and here I'm just showing you
the demographics of this cohort but the
main thing to point out is that we have
certain comorbidities that we have been
seen in the past the seem to be
predominant in people that are becoming
very severe and in our cohort here in
Chile we're finding that hypertension
chronic industrial disease and also
obesity are predominant comorbidities of
these people that are becoming severe in
the past
obesity has been shown to be risk factor
for impassive influenza disease but as
far as we understand
this would be one of the first studies
showing that arterial hypertension has a
big role to play in regards to severity
in felicitations another important thing
to know is that our cohort does not have
any specific bias or discrimination so
we use samples from patients that are
recruited from all ages and we can also
say that in regards to the severe
patients since that the males are more
severe at least in Muskoka [ __ ] about
59% of the severe patients are often
paired male and we in this particular
cohort we only have a two to three
basins really - there have become
succumb to infection that were dying due
to infection so here I'm showing you the
first set of data that we can
extrapolate out of cytokine expression
profiles so to do this what we do is to
run multiplex analysis of 18 cytokines
and chemokines that we know are
important during acute phase and
compilation phase of infection influenza
specific cohorts so the first thing that
we do this is an unsupervised analysis
where we ask all right from additions
can we group first samples due to how
similar they are to each other so that's
why it is an unbiased we are not sending
them where they come from or what they
they were taking but yes can we do an
analysis where we can guess room samples
that look closer to each other and then
on top of that we start putting some
colors in chilies into these data as
first of all we look at subtype and here
you can see that there are squares and
triangles that show whether sample I
came from a patient infected with an
h1n1 virus or an h3n2 virus and as you
can see there is not particular
trend of - what's up times these viruses
these patients were infected with now
what is interesting if we color now when
the samples were taken so these are
blood samples in which me with the
cytokine analysis we can actually start
seeing very nice trends as you can see
as they zero which would mean the day
when the samples were taken upon the
original consent so at the time of the
consent they clustered together and form
a very nice cluster of yellow cytokines
that are are being expressed early on
during infection the opposite if the
more purple you have is later time
points during infection so you can also
see that the more purple samples or
cytokines in this case are grouping
together what is interesting about these
is now if we look at the specific arrows
these are the most predominant cytokines
that are being expressed in these
patients so very early on you can see
that for example I'll ten I pretend I oh
six and I all ten are becoming
predominant cytokines that are being
expressed early on during infection and
then we have some other cytokines such
as such as IO for i/o 13 there are seem
to be over expressing at the later time
points so this is very nice because it
allow us without putting any into
analysis you know what side events are
being triggered early on and how they
compared to science there have been been
trigger later on but also it allowed us
to discriminate what is the time point
that we can consider early on versus
example to consider a post infection and
the particular time point was set at day
14 so this analysis told us that
anything that we can look at day 14 of
Homer's we can actually prove them as
time points which will give us
statistically significant analysis now
if we look at the this particular time
who is so a cute face sample what we
asked can we predict some certain
cytokines that will allowance to tell
that these will be markers associated
with severity early on and in the same
way can we predict by markers any sign
again that will be associated with
decreased infection or decreased very
early on so as you can see here we have
very very nice data and clean data
telling us that il-6 and il-8 would be
early predictors associated with
increased severity in the other hand we
have interferon gamma which was
associated as a molecular factor being
associated with decreased severity so
this is an interesting set of results
because we could potentially take an
early sample from patients and try to
predict whether this particular patient
early on will be the chances of this
person of having severe disease or not
according to these particular
side-effects that's so that's that's one
potential application of some of these
analysis I have to tell you that this is
still predominant in preliminary data
and we're moving on to more
sophisticated infinitive analysis to try
to confirm that this are the case ok so
now I'd like to show you analysis of
samples that we have from non acute
phase time points which like I said
before these are samples taken on day 14
on or after the onset of symptoms so as
you can see here we have determined a
different set of cytokines that were
associated with severe disease such as
Iowa in the Alpha Iota 90/10 among
others and we also get some
cytokines that are associated with
decreased
it's very such as I Oh 1301 beta I am 13
what is interesting about this is that
if you from a temporal point of view if
you take into account that unusual
influenza infection takes about seven
days this means that even after seven
days there is a lot of immune responses
that might actually be moderately
modulating this is rarity so this is
something that we're continuing to
analyze further so here I want to show
you some of the global analysis that we
can actually do with the same data and
here is a summary slide where we can put
together a number of different
parameters that we can measure so first
on the on the right hand side or we can
see the risk groups and as you can see
the red are people that don't have risk
in particular sorry the red are people
are have risk in their situation this
means children under two years of age or
elderly which are above 65 years of age
then we have a number of different
communities that we a sense and one
thing that is interesting to highlight
there is that we can see in the severe
group which is the bottom panels that
acting on hypertension and
cardiovascular disease are over
represented in our cohort again as I
said this would be the first time that
this has been described for such risk
pasture for fringe severity and also
there on the on the other side we can
see the cytokine expression levels and
as I said before we can see a number of
the cytokines such as aisle 8a a 6 out
of 10 and I pretend being representative
or over-represented in the severe groups
another interesting factor is now in
consider vaccine status for some of
these patients we see that some patients
that are very severe have been
vaccinated and
have not been vaccinated hands we
believe that if patients have
susceptibility which are to do with age
or specific comorbidities people can
still get infected and also develop a
very severe disease so the role of of
understanding better the role of I've
seen in this population I think is high
priority for future research now I want
to move to the next phase which is what
about the virus now if we study the
virus can we also associate some of the
factors that might be actually
responsible because of virus genotypes
or virulence factors that we can find
there so we have actually and then
different analysis with samples obtained
from different patients that are severe
this is a study that has been performed
by a graduate student in which we'll use
samples from 27 25 patients from
patients that range from nine month old
to seventy six years of age and a number
of these were hospitalized and met our
criteria of being severe which means
hospitalized for more than 48 hours or
by being a critical care unit and as in
the previous study we also find that
obesity immune suppression and
cardiovascular disease
Thrun and hypertension are common
communities in this group here I just
want to show you now when we do a very
simple analysis so what we do we should
go back to the previous slide and I'm
gonna show you data from these patients
and where all of the samples from these
patients have been sequence the entire
genome and in some cases or most of the
cases we have been able to like I said
we take swabs from different time points
so we have been able to obtain food
genomes from different samples of the
during the acute phase of infection so
this allows us to follow the virus to
understand whether the virus has mutated
or has acquired mutations over
the course of infection and like I said
most of these patients are very severe
including some two patients on the
bottom here that succumb to infection so
the as you can see there is not a
particular virus on on age or gender in
this group so we think that this
analysis continues to for us to
understand what happens with the virus
during acute infection in severe
individuals now if we do the simple
analysis which is just to ask by what's
called a phylogenetic analysis and this
is an unrooted analysis which means that
we are not in how to with each other but
how they will actually are grouped by
how similar they are to each other we
find that most samples that we are able
to sequence sequentially over time from
the same patient joined together and
here I have highlighted them with bars
on the sides as you can see where we
have done analysis for the hemagglutinin
the chase segments for and in the
nominal a segment six but as I'm showing
here in the arrows in certain cases we
can see a couple samples that come from
the same individual but actually that
they don't group together but they group
with different viruses meaning that
those viruses actually do not prefer
related to each other but it seems to be
diverging apart okay so this is just a
representation of how these viruses can
be actually found to be different within
the same individual so the question is
what is different about them so we did
an extensive analysis of some of these
samples and look at the databases to see
how some of the mutations that we can
find in these viruses whether there are
common mutations found on the databases
whether they're moderately common or
rare or they are actually very rare and
with this we did some studies about the
frequency of each of the positions
where they land in the influence of
genome so we do these long analysis and
what I'm showing you here on the top is
what we are representation of the human
Newton analysis that we do in the what
we see here in the Peaks that we you see
in the graph and up on the top is how
variable these regions are in the
database and the little bars on the
bottom of that show you where we find
mutations of our cohort so as you can
see there are spread out pretty much all
throughout the molecule and on the
bottom of that we we have highlighted
the functional sites that are known for
influences such as the receptor binding
site or the anti ending size so here we
can actually start seeing where some
limitations lie within the genome and at
the bottom we also now map in the
particular mutations that we have find
from our patients in crystal structures
and as you can see again just taking the
first look it looks like mutations can
occur in different places now if we this
structural analysis we'll go back into
the analysis of frequency how
frequencies and sequences are
represented in databases we find that
some of these sequences are common the
ones that are light blue some of them
are unique and to our patients but that
had been also pretty shown or being
present in some sequences reported in
NCBI and the yellow mutations are some
of the mutations that have not been
shown in NCBI before and it seems to be
unique to the patients that we have
analyzed in this study so we do a
similar analysis for DNA again then we
will show you on the time the frequency
of the variation seen on the NCBI the
bars represent the different mutations
that we find in our cohort as you can
see some of them are blue so there seems
to be reuse that are very variable which
is not a it is expected and again the
functional size
put them there and then we map them in
the crystal structure and look at some
of the mutations that are unique so
we're actually interests in trying to
understand some of the Enigma tations in
your cohort because we hypothesize that
they will allow us to tell whether some
of these mutations might have
contributed to this is severity so here
I'm showing you some of the summaries of
the same analysis but we have done for
all the genes and just to highlight that
this is not a phenomenon that only
occurs in the micro proteins which are
the surface proteins of the viruses of
the virus but also occurs on the
internal genes so it seems like the
influenza virus since it doesn't have a
an error correction capacity in their
polymerase it can actually make
mutations throughout the genome but we
have also started looking at some of the
mutations that we think are interesting
because it shows for example mutations
that change from one day to the next but
the way of saying from the same in the
video which we mean that the virus
actually had a transition and a mutation
within a day or two in the same host and
that's for example highlighted here in
PB one with the red versus the methane
in the change within two three days two
links in a similar scenario we have seen
in hae and an A and these are the two
cases that I want to show you whether we
have followed that and then functional
analysis and found some interesting
results
so here H a na are actually expected to
have a lot of changes this is what has
it been seen in in the databases and in
nature in general these are prone
different genomes that are prone to
change because of immune selection
pressure and also because of other other
patient's that they need to do in order
to to have a functional replication of
the virus but I want to point into these
an 18 mutation resale new to me in here
that is highlighted and also in the case
of an a I would like to show you and
point you to this eye solution 2 to 3 in
mutation in the new terminal is that
occurs in two separate patients that we
think have a functional activity and
they may actually continue to fashion
severity so here I'm showing you a slide
that summarizes all ditched
translational changes that we have found
in different patients as I'm showing
here on the top even with patient 3 from
2011 we have two mutations that have are
not really in any of the previously
described functional size but there are
dissertations that change within four
days so that means that a particular day
we found one mutation and then for later
for daily things later recommendation
was fixed at a different with a
different amino acid one of those
mutations is this mutation in rossini
two to three which is actually close and
within the catalytic side of the
neuraminidase activity or protein and
these we see a transition from an iron
into a nice solution so the a solution
is actually the one side original amino
acid in the position so it would be the
my thiamine that actually changed and I
will show you in a minute what we think
was happening there so we see other
changes in other patients that some of
them again fall within functional sites
but I want to also highlight a patient
25 at the bottom here were where he the
rescue number 180 falls right in the
middle of antigen excited SE and again
this has a transition from a licen to a
glutamine within three days from in the
same patient so again if I show you the
word patient three so the original
neuraminidase mutation mutation that i
described and it comes from this is a
patient the
had immune has cancer deceased and
having news repression so this is a
twelve year old now that was that had
influenza for several days so if you
look at this particular patient as you
can see now the course of infection the
original set of symptoms came a few days
later after in front and after he was
hospitalized for other reasons and then
once he was confirmed as an influence
positive then he got two rounds of the
antiviral or some tamari which is the
commonly news burns antiviral the
samples that we actually analyzed and an
absurdist at this change was taken on
day 12 after the onset of symptoms from
flu so this patient had a very prolonged
infection from from influenza and four
days later we took another sample and we
found some changes so here in the
molecule I'm chain panel B I'm showing
you where this mutation poles and it
falls right in the middle of the
catalytic site and we think that this
particular mutation changes from a
medallion entire solution and in fact
Emmitt I mean it's a different residue
that actually might interact and get in
the way of the catalytic site so if we
look at this closer in fact we find that
these methionine might actually have a
steric hindrance in regards to the
action of tamarin because it will
prevent it at least to fully insert into
the pocket of the catalytic site now
indeed I'm showing you what we found
when we viruses so I said they found
that the predominant on the viruses
sequence by Illumina had the methionine
which would be the what we think was our
system mutation to also to America
only a little bit of the original wild
type
I still use say 16 once
Neos remember the second round of timer
was terminated more overhanded we can
see a reversion to the original I
solicitor using which is the the
wild-type phenotype so in order to
determine whether it was a true
resistant mutation with it actual the
first was to the star analysis which
actually allows us to tell whether the
neuraminidase activity of these two
different viruses the one with the
methionine versus a isoleucine and
different inhibitory concentration 50
and we had a result that told us that
there was at least two to three for
higher ic50 in the methionine viruses
than the wealthy virus meaning that this
could actually be a potential persistent
phenotype and then to confirm that what
we did was to run a competition analysis
where we actually rescued this virus by
reverse genetics and co-infected cells
in the presence or absence of some
chamomile and different concentrations
of the drug and as you can see in the
first panel where was there was no
sometime earlier pretty much the two
viruses were found at the similar
frequencies when we miss infections by
Illumina and we passage disparities
three times in cells under the same
conditions now as you can see we use one
micromolar 10 micromolar a hundred micro
molar of Awesome camera view so we see
those dependent effect where the
methionine actually outcompetes
the isoleucine virus in the presence of
some possible terminal therefore this
confirms that this particular mutation
is and confers an antiviral resistance
awesome camera which could also explain
why this individual had a prolonged
affection
and a severe outcome so the second case
is this patient 25 that I mentioned this
was from a very young individual that
had also been vaccinated so what we
think with this particular notation now
if we look at the clinical data upon the
onset of symptoms we took two samples on
day 5 and on day 8 and we also see this
transitional change from a lysine to a
newt amine and and then you can see that
this is right in the middle of an
important ante and excite assay which is
shown here B's all right now if we look
at how this virus was represented when
we do a next-generation sequence II we
can see that the on day 5 the virus had
the wild-type original gene no time with
a lysine in the particular residue
but then on they a change to the what we
think is escaped phenotype now if we go
back to the sequencing the sequences
that are available in gene bank we can
see at the beginning of the infection
with this pandemic strain which is the
h1n1 pandemic strain that naturally
seasonal seasonally most of the viruses
or 100% of the viruses have this lysine
residue at that position up until 2012
where we start seeing some of the
transitions - in this particular residue
- different genotypes but then from
almost 2013 onwards then the Q is a
predominant in no time in this virus so
that is very interesting because we have
what we think is a phenomenon in a
single patient that we can see that
transition we could actually be escaping
it embarrass in in an individual now if
we look at what has been described right
at that time if we look at this
phylogenetic tree in 2000
13 2014 this particular K 100 Q amino
acid change was also a key determinant
on how the virus is circulated over time
also indicating the distressing you is
probably unimportant residues and in
this particular publication they had
also pointed out that it could this
could be an escaped mutation that held
the virus overcome pre-six in immunity
so in order to try to address this we
also did a competition experiment again
we rescued viruses containing either the
[Music]
lysine or the glutamine amino acid and
then we come infected cells in the
presence of premium serie against the
license or the wild-type ours
so this serie in theory we'd only be
able to neutralize the acid but not the
key if this was in fact an escaped
mutant and when we can see this this
again this was a pre-existing serie
obtained from a patient that was
infected only with the viruses that we
know had a lysine in that particular
region so we also see a dose-dependent
effect with the higher titer of
antibodies that we use in this
confection we start seeing the
predominance of the key virus in the
course of a single infection so again is
also strongly so yes that this
particular mutation is an escape Newton
so this would be a potential continued
nuclear mouton in a particular patient
that have been proxy mated before so to
summarize we think that these
low-frequency mutations are have high
variability in some cases and could
actually explain some of the this is how
come some of the these mutations as the
one will expect most of them are located
in the surface and I think what is
interesting is that from the clinical
isolates we have if we're able to follow
this virus over
we find some functional important
mutations that in this case were present
in neuraminidase and also in the human
lieutenant proteins and that could
actually be some of the reasons why
these people were affected for prolonged
periods of time and we're also severe so
with then and I hope I have shown you
some of the analysis that we are done in
a systems way with human data that we
can actually use for understanding
molecular factors that are modulating
influenza this is severity so with this
I'll just finish up acknowledging my
group and different people have
participated in their studies or
chemical Catholic University here in
Chile
many of our clinicians and nurses that
have contributed to recruiting patients
and obtaining clinical data as well as
some of these studies that have been
done in close collaborations with a
Icahn School of Medicine with dr. go for
CS astray I'm a Banco foreign Cramer and
also with the J craig Venter Institute
prison poem did one worth when he was
there and a number of other people and
ongoing collaborations we're actually
doing with the John Garang Casanova and
some other people at the University of
Singapore where we are continuing to do
some long-term analysis of influenza and
other viruses and of course the funding
that comes from many different sources
some of this funding comes from Chile
through different grants to the National
Commission of Science and Technology and
also from NIH through the Sears Network
the Crypt Center and also from phenomics
consortium funded by NIAID and with that
I'll be happy to answer questions thank
you very much